[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse platini manqué et mara des
bois continue de voler les pauvres pour
donner aux riches
la chasse a été fructueuse tout l'art
ailleurs mérite salaire
d'accord et en salaire à toi je vais te
le faire tu voi avoir le plus beau mon
salaire le voilà mon salaire mais côté
six ans pour mon père c'est pour la
vanité 7,7 et de n'avons pas faire de 9
mon couturier jean attila thatcher la
fougasse tu t'imagines pas que j'ai tu
paies tout ça pour payer ses créanciers
ton père ta famille dassault est à
cousines ont dit voilà avec toi mdash je
vais faire mon band aid depuis le temps
que je peux le faire je vais le faire
ces points borne aide mon disque à
disque
oui et pourquoi tu veux faire un
histoire parce que tu trouves petit
chante bien je suis le rossignol le
rossignol de la méditerranée morel c'est
joli ce studio est résolu on a bien fait
de le piquer faire tromper steeve être
chanteur devra faire de jolies chansons
ramené beaucoup d'argent et moi je serai
un imprésario imprésario an hini
imprésario kézaco petit robert
imprésario sorte de batraciens ventouses
qui se colle sur le dos d'une vedette de
cinéma ou de la chanson
il ne fait rien sinon qu'il partage ses
repas ses femmes et ses revenus synonyme
johnny stark ou monsieur 50% vous en
page 32
non mais ça va pas te rendre mes femmes
toi apparemment des femmes et la moitié
de ses revenus
la voiture donc je voudrais tu vois mes
dix dons en échange de conseils une
petite commission alors tu m'écoutes
mora tu chantes là devant le micro
tu t'appliques oui tu te détends où il
fait beau sourire ans j'ai le trac je
les langues
[Musique]
je t'ai rien contre eux
peu me
tu n'as rien fait pour soi rocher
un peu
je t'aime pour tous
mona
on rien je le sens nouveau
défunt
je serai toujours
son cochon
je suis pas un jour
comment
c'est plus fort que moi
[Musique]
te